foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar a fast
High throughput all-in-one
pharmacogenomics workflow that targets
actionable snps and cnvs and supports
customization
I am Megan Pascal of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by standard biotools
to learn more visit standardbio.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Bill
hunt director microfluidics product
management at standard biotools bill you
may now begin your presentation
thank you for the lovely introduction
and Welcome to our audience today's
presentation will be on pharmacogenomics
uh we'll be I'll be presenting on a new
product that we've introduced
commercially for fast High throughput
workflow PGX workflow that detects
actionable Snips and cmvs while
supporting customization my name is Bill
hunt I'm the director of product
management at standard biotools in the
microfluidics division
so just to give a bit of an overview
about standard biotools and who we are
since we're not necessarily yet a
household name in in the field we've
been leveraging about 20 years of
innovation in terms of tech expertise
and proven Technologies and various
spaces including molecular biology
genomics and proteomics our headquarters
are in South San Francisco California we
have research and Manufacturing
facilities in the U.S Canada as well as
Singapore employees worldwide are about
600 and we have a Global Network of
fields application Specialists field
service engineers and product support
Engineers that service and support the
products that we sell we're also ISO
compliant for both design development
manufacturing and distribution
and formally we were known as fluid I'm
so for those who are perhaps familiar
with the technology but perhaps
unfamiliar with the company name
um we were previously known as fluidime
moving into the types of product or
business units that we support we have a
multi-ohmic approach that's powered by
revolutionary Technologies in flow
cytometry spatial Imaging and
microfluidics today's Focus will be on
the last uh the last section
microflitics and PCR we'll be talking
about our Advanta assays and kits the
microfluidic chips that fueled the
assays as well as our instrument
platforms that are used with our
products to produce a complete solution
um and getting focusing on the genomic
Solutions and what we can offer Labs
through our products you can see on the
screen there are a number of
applications that are available through
our products mostly in genotyping and
gene expression library next Generation
sequencing Library prep today's Focus
will be on PGX testing which combines
aspects of both genotyping and gene
expression as well as copy number
variation
getting into the pharmacogenomics
overview recognizing some some
individuals participating today may have
a background in pharmacogenomics whereas
some do not I thought it best to start
with a little bit of an overview as to
the the uh the segment of the market in
which pharmacogenomics plays so it's
considered a Cornerstone of precision
medicine that aims to tailor medical
treatment to each person or to a group
of individuals through integration of
inter inherited genetic variants
um and the key benefits in terms of
research are they reduce the risk of
adverse drug reactions or adrs they can
increase the likelihood that a drug will
be effective and the main kind of
distillation of all this is that it
pairs an individual with the right
medication at the right dose at the
right time based on that person's
genetic profile so you'll find that
certain drugs work well for one
individual but don't for others and a
lot of it comes down to their genetic
profile and how those how the their
genes get expressed uh in terms of
metabolism of those drugs
in terms of research areas it's it's
pretty diverse key areas are Psychiatry
pain management oncology and
cardiovascular disease but there are
many others
if you look at the global risk of
adverse drug reactions it comes down to
high use of medications worldwide so
I've chosen a few statistics to
represent the global audience
um and in the case of the UK you've got
reports of over 26 percent of adults
taking prescription medications in
Australia about 35 percent take
prescription medications every day in
Canada 65 percent of people over the age
of 40 and between 40 and 75 79 take at
least one prescription drug which is
referred to as polypharmacy so basically
an individual when they're taking more
than two medications it's considered a
polypharmacy event and there's a study
of individuals 65 and older that
revealed that polypharmacy is common at
65 percent with 37 reporting major
polypharmacy meaning that they're taking
more than five medications at the same
time so you can see when you start
having this number of medications the
risk increases that those medications
may not work well together or for a
specific individual
um focusing last on the United States
you've got over 4 billion people or 4
billion prescriptions issued each year
with only 50 showing the expected
therapeutic efficacy efficacy and
globally uh 35 million people have drug
use disorders based on a report from the
United Nations so there's a lot of
evidence that there's a high use of
medications those you the usages aren't
always as effective as they should be so
monitoring for Effectiveness is
something that poly or that
pharmacogenomics can provide
getting into the drug metabolism element
of this there are different phases of
enzymatic biotransformation of a
medication once it's administered the
key areas are phase one and phase two
phase one is shown in the figure on the
upper right of the slide and it's
focused on drug modification processes
and you'll see that a lot of the
cytochrome p450 system genes are are
represented in that that pie in segments
of that pie the second phase two which
is on the lower figure is focuses on
drug conjugation processes such as
transferases the key purpose of this
slide isn't necessarily to focus on the
metabolism itself but it's to show that
there's a fair number of genes involved
in that metabolism and this is not
considered an exhausted list so there's
many more
um focusing on the what what the impact
of differential biotransformation can be
you've got individuals that are
considered Ultra rapid metabolizers so
these are people who have increased
metabolic activity when you administered
a medication they metabolize it very
quickly then you've got people who are
deemed extensive which is considered a
normal state of fermentabolic activity
and then you've got low or slow
metabolizers they have a reduced
metabolic activity and then there are
finally individuals with poor metabolism
having little to no metabolic activity
so this goes back to the earlier point
that you could have say four individuals
receiving the exact same medication but
there could be four different responses
based on the individual's metabolic rate
based on their genetics
and the biotransformation can be further
affected by other medications the
individuals on this pulls in the
polypharmacy mentioned earlier as well
as biological compounds in diet and the
effects can either inhibit or induce
metabolism further so it makes it for a
very Dynamic and complex scenario
there are various types of gene variants
that are important in pharmacogenomics
single nucleotide polymeromorphisms or
Snips are represent a variation with a
gene specific to a single base change by
comparison there are copy number
variants that are alternate numbers of
copies of a specific gene or a gene
segment within the individual
and then there are star alleles which is
pharmacogenomics specific nomenclature
used to define a physical grouping of
genomic variants that tend to be
inherited together or also referred to
as a haplotype and these are usually
associated with protein activity levels
and then the final term that often comes
up are hybrid alleles and this
represents a recombination product of
two genes that results in a
non-functional product so undetected
hybrid genes could cause an
overestimation of certain gene activity
specifically sip2d6 which is a which is
a key Gene within any pharmacogenomics
panel and then detection allows for a
more accurate phenotype prediction based
on the genomic the genotype data
there are a number of resources this is
just a small list that I've I thought I
I provide to in the audience and these
groups work together to educate guide
and support the use of pharmacogenomics
in regular practice so starting from the
upper left you've got farmvar which
catalogs various a little variation of
genes that Impact Drug metabolism you've
got cpic or the clinical
pharmacogenomics implementation
Consortium that provides guidelines that
helps clinicians understand how to use
this information if they choose to do so
and it also helps them to optimize drug
therapy by by identifying scenarios
where if a certain genetic profile
appears perhaps they would make a
modification in the medication chosen
for that individual and then finally
Farm gkb which collects curates and
disseminates knowledge about the impact
of human genetic variation on drug
responses so again these are just three
other organizations that are involved
there are various journals that are
dedicated to pharmacogenomics there are
additional um institutions around the
world that that support the same effort
so moving out of the pharmacogenomics
overview into the advantage of
pharmacogenomics assay I thought we'd
start by giving an overview of what this
is so what we did in the beginning when
we were developing this product we
wanted to understand what the what the
key pain points
um a lab experiences as they try to
implement and utilize PGX research
testing and this was based on various
discussions we had with Labs that are
involved today in performing
pharmacogenomics testing or we're
considering implementing
pharmacogenomics testing so you've got
the pain Point shown on the left which
are not that uncommon or many of them
are not uncommon to other disciplines as
well but things such as lab operation
constraints having limited space limited
staff limited resources in general
there's also High operating and
maintenance costs to implement a test
some Labs reported no resident expertise
in pharmacogenomics
others reported difficulty in optimizing
Multiplex reactions or that the content
that was available to them through
commercial means was inflexible
and then they finally got into the
difficulty in reporting or interpreting
the results and then in some cases there
could be a long lead time to report
results to clients resulting in them
missing their service commitments to
their clients so if they indicated they
would return the results in two to three
days and they missed that it impacts it
has implications Downstream to the at
the client level
so ways in which standard biotools can
help address these pain points is
through our low footprint X9 real-time
PCR system which I'll Showcase in a
moment that supports many genomic
research applications including gene
expression genotyping copy number
variation and we're planning to add more
to that platform
there are we offer nanoscale reaction
volumes that lower the cost by reducing
the amount of reagent and Sample
consumption involved in a given
application
our PGX kit includes all the reagents
and consumables required to run the
assay with the exceptions being for the
Buckle swabs used to collect the sample
and then General lab consumables such as
pipette tips
reagent reservoirs and things of that
nature
our Quark asset content is based on
professional guidelines so it goes back
to some of those professional
organizations I showcased on an earlier
slide including seat pick and Farm gkb
microfluidics open architecture makes it
easy to add remove or replicate assays
on demand so go into the issue with
difficulty with Multiplex reactions in
an inflexible content we have an open
architecture and every assay is tested
independently of all the other assays so
it's easy to actually change out an
assay remove it or replicate it do
whatever you need to do to augment or
customize the configuration to suit the
needs of your lab
and then the microfluidic technology
also provides the option to customize
the content as needed so you'll see that
in our panel we left a few of our assay
inlets open so that Labs could add
custom content based on their their
needs
and then closing out with analysis
software that reports the snip and CND
results together with star allele calls
and then finally being able to run the
Snips and cmvs together in a single run
that takes about four hours to complete
so there are a number of products on
Market that require separate runs
separate Technologies for Snips and cmvs
our workflow it combines the two in the
single workflow so every single sample
on our run is tested for all the snip
assays and all the CMD assays at the
same time
so if you're focusing on kind of our
presentation what we what we um conceive
as the value this product delivers to
the users
um I'm going to focus on the gray text
in the middle of the slide so basically
just reading it off the slide that our
assay allows you to process Snips and
cmvs for up to 96 samples in a single
workflow with the option of using
extraction free Buckle swabs or
extracted DNA if you if you choose to do
so achieving results in approximately
four hours with actionable content that
can be customized to meet your needs
additional attributes are shown in the
text that follow so as we validated a
panel of 74 Gene targets derived from
cpic and farm gkb based on guidelines
our flexibility I mentioned being able
to customize content is needed the
single Plex Simplicity that eliminates
the complexity of trying to get multiple
assays in a multiplex to work well
together and also difficulty if you ever
need to change one of having to
revalidate the entire Multiplex and then
being able to conserve volumes of your
samples of your reagent of reaction or
your reagents because we're operating at
a nanometer scale
getting into the content of our
particular product you'll see on the
slide here we've got 17 genes that are
implicated in drug metabolism Pathways
contributing a total of 71 Snips or
indels plus three cmvs and an rnas PSA
as a control these targets support 40 of
the 43cpic identified level a and level
B targets
you look at it in a plate or in a plate
layout the the assays that are shown in
that are shaded in blue are the the
Snips and the indels and you can have
the the RS coordinates as well as the
gene designation
um are provided the the cells shown in
yellow are the open inlets that are
available for customization and then the
red cell or the rose cells on the far
right represent the CMB acids you'll see
that each of the CMV assays is tested in
quadruplicate this gives us statistical
power for the analysis since those are
the assays that are involved in CMV
getting back to the cpic content I
mentioned that there are 43 targets that
are Level a and level B and you can see
that our asset the Advanta assay covers
40 of those 43 the other suppliers or
three other suppliers that are shown on
this table it gives the information that
they that was available from their
product literature and you can see that
they provide a lower number of targets
that are cpic Level A and B and even if
in cases where they provide more targets
than than the Advanta assay we can comp
or supplement by adding the
customization so by being able to
customize users can configure their
product to meet their exact needs
um I've often asked about the star
alleles that are covered by the assays
in our panel and this slide is intended
to share that information with you so
you can see the various genes on the
left and the star alleles shown on the
right especially the high number of star
alleles associated with SIP 2d6 which I
mentioned was a key Target in
pharmacogenomics panel and this is all
based on farmvar database version 5.2.8
getting into sample requirements and
what how what what can be used as input
for our assay we require genomic DNA
from Human samples at 10 nanograms per
microliter which is our recommendation
although we support up to 50 nanogram
nanograms per microliter so there is a
range of input that works perfectly fine
with our workflow and our performance
in terms of sample prep requirements we
use buccal swabs that can be available
for any major supplier R and our R D
team has evaluated the Buckle swab
suppliers and products shown on the
screen so if anybody wanted to replicate
what our r d has done these are the the
products that we've used and they all
worked well in our hands so there are
products from ISO Helix Thermo Fisher as
well as Puritan
we also offer an extraction free process
which is a 15-minute heat inactivation
of the buccal swab eluent as well as for
labs that prefer to use extracted
material that works as well and our R D
team has used the magmac system from
thermofisher but you'll see in the
coming upcoming slide there's also a
product from Beckman that we've used as
well and that that also worked um well
with our with our workflow
get talking about workflow here's an
overview of the steps that are involved
in our workflow starting with sample
collection and extraction
once we've completed that step you move
into the preamplification of genomic DNA
at 10 to 50 nanograms per microliter
um you then transfer that onto an assay
and you prepare your assay and Sample
mix preparation and load that onto the
um our customized microchip the
integrated fluidic circuit and then once
that's completed you transfer that to
our biomark I'm sorry our X9 system
um and that system does all the IFC
loading and data collection transferring
the final data to our analysis software
where it generates your your raw data
your genotype your copy number
information as well as giving you the
star allele calling results and you can
see that the steps in the middle steps
two through four take about four hours
to complete from start to finish
and the workflow includes the extraction
free method if you choose to go that
route it offers the ability to detected
targeted Snips and cmvs in the same run
and it also uses a new script that we
developed to help bring the time of our
workflows down so there there's um
there's uh there was work done on the
instrument workflow as well not just the
the layout of how we would approach it
from a manual perspective
so since our integrated fluidic circuits
may be new to some in the audience I
thought it would be useful to show a
slide to kind of depicts what they are
and how they compare with the commonly
used lab component which are the micro
title plates that are that are often
used and so by comparison integrated
fluidic circuits what they do is they
allow you can perform multiple PCR based
applications including targeted NGS
Library preparation we have specific
formats that support that purpose
and you can see in this particular
example I'm showing a library prep 48.48
chip the digit on the left represents
the number of assay inlets the digit on
the right represents the number of
um I'm sorry the digit on the left is
the number of sample inlets the digit on
the right is the number of assay inlets
and so that's the general nomenclature
of our of our ifcs
and this allows for scalable sample
throughput so you can go from one chip
format to another they all work the same
general way they all have the same
general structure so you can go from one
chip to another without changing
technology you can achieve lower cost
and higher operating efficiency through
the miniaturization of the reactions so
what happens is you load your samples on
the into the sample inlets you load your
assay mixes into the assay inlets once
it's loaded onto our instrument the
instrument then combines
um a portion of each sample Inlet
material with each assay in the material
used in those in The Matrix within the
center of the IFC so if you look at this
particular IFC it's a 48.48 that means
there are 48 times 48 individual
reaction chambers within the IFC so
every sample gets combined with every
assay at the individual level
and because it's open architecture as I
mentioned it's easy to add or change
things over time as needed and this this
design is automation friendly it's been
designed to be automated we have a
number of labs that have higher
throughput workflows and they've they've
been able to use lab automation systems
to automate the the preparation of the
reagents as well as the loading of the
IFC itself
so comparing this to a micro tighter
plate or a micro well plate you start
out the same you're still making your
assay mixes and your your sample Master
mixes and you're dispensing those into
the appropriate positions within a micro
tighter plate or into the IFC depending
on which one you're using the key
difference is on the microtider plate
side each sample is interrogated only by
the targets that are in the same well so
if you start getting a a high Multiplex
getting you know four five six targets
getting them to work all you know well
together in a given well may be
challenging so you may end up splitting
them and using two Wells to accommodate
the number of targets you're
interrogating that means you're using
twice as much reagent you're using twice
as much sample or three times depending
on how many inlets you're using whereas
on the IFC side every sample is
interrogated by every assay and we use a
very small amount of material to do that
so you're really conserving expensive
components such as your reagents and
you're conserving precious samples
some of the advantages of
um our our Tech our microfluid
technology over microtite or microwell
plates we can support up to 192 targets
per sample depending on the format of
the IFC you're using it does facilitate
workflow automation I mentioned the lab
automation capabilities earlier it
minimizes the use of expensive enzymes
and master mixes conserves usage of
pressure samples it's easy to optimize
multiple targets because you're testing
them individually
it's easy to add remove change assays as
needed and then finally it does maximize
your throughput you can go all the way
from batch sizes of 48 up to sample
batches of 192.
in terms of the flexibility sometimes
it's easier to show it um through
animation than it is just just to talk
about it so here's another version a
different format of our IFC this one it
happens to be a 4848 Dynamic array IFC
that's used for genotyping or gene
expression so if here if I have an
application I could say that I'm using
45 of my 48 inlets for my first round of
design I've got three extra inlets left
over for customization in the future
perhaps a week a month a year from now I
decide I want to add or I need to add
additional targets so I can do that
using those three inlets those three
pink or reddish tinged uh inlets that I
show on the lower right of the screen
likewise in the middle of the of the
field there's a dark red dot that now
appears that's a case where perhaps that
assay the original blue assay is not
performing as well as I wanted it to
over time or it needs to be removed
because it's no longer important I can
just swap that out and replace it with
another assay of my choose using and not
affect any of the other assays that are
shown in blue because again everything
is tested individually
I mentioned that this is all enabled
through our instrumentation we offer the
new X9 real-time PCR system this this
represents the latest in a lineage that
dates back to the biomark for the so for
those who may be familiar with the
biomark and the biomark HD systems this
is a replacement for that platform over
time we've been able to implement newer
technology shrink down the size quite
considerably and it's designed to keep
the same functionality of the biomark
lineage meaning that it offers High data
output with more than 9 000 individual
nanolated reactions in a single run that
allows you to ensure you're getting a
comprehensive sample profile with
minimal operator contribution so you're
getting more data deeper insights and
less effort to analyze a large amount of
data in a single run
um I just for those who are familiar
with the biomark that is the instrument
shown in the lower left side of the
screen and when you pair that with the
Juno system on the upper right our
historical technology involved an IFC
controller that would load and process
your ifcs and then you would transfer it
into the biomark for final analysis
that's where the Optics are that's where
you do the real-time PCR analysis what
we've now done is we've combined the
functionality of both those systems into
one and it's six times smaller than the
biomark HD itself so it's a much more
um
uh lab-friendly system meaning that if
you're if you're constrained for space
this is about the size of a desktop
computer but the traditional desktop
computer towers that you may be familiar
with and it does perform all the
functions of Juno so it can accept any
of the IFC formats that we provide
there's no need for a PC connection to
control the platform it's all integrated
it has the same robust performance as
the predecessor the biomark HD and we've
been in the process of adding menu and
that will expand over the course of the
next year two years the pharmacogenomics
assay is the first application that was
developed specifically for the X9 system
this shows an earlier version of the of
the instrument I just show it just so
you have a context of the size because
it shows a person interacting with the
platform so you can see that this is
about the size it would take up in your
lab
um and it does a number of functions
that um were Consolidated from other
platforms
so going into the Express Scripts these
I mentioned earlier these are
contributing to our workflowing and
giving us the up approximately four
hours of run time from
um basically start to finish and so our
main objective was to come up with new
scripts that improved the work the
turnaround time of applications run on
the IFC that's used to run PGX without
changing the IFC design without
requiring additional consumables and
labor and without impacting performance
we did this through modifying how the
IFC is processed Downstream or actually
I should say Upstream of the thermal
cycling itself so the thermal cycling
process didn't change at all what we
were able to do is modify how we Prime
the chip how we mix the reagents how we
load them into the individual reaction
Chambers all that we were able to reduce
the amount of time and also eliminate a
number of user interactions that were
not
they didn't take a lot of time but they
did draw you away from other things you
might be doing in the lab so this way
you're interacting with the system once
up front and once you've loaded the IFC
onto the instrument it's basically walk
away and you can see how the time
changes how the times uh were reduced by
as a result of the Express Script
giving into performing giving some
information about performance I'll go
through these fairly quickly but it's
the standard Scatter Plots or cluster
plots that you may be familiar with and
it just shows you how we how performance
was retained by when you're using the
Express Script as versus the original
loading scripts um the predecessors of
Express you can see the performance is
about the same in fact it's a little bit
better on the Express Script
likewise for gene expression you've got
the Express Script on the left the
current the predecessor on the right you
can see how we were able to get a
tighter standard deviation by going with
the Express Script because more of the
process is automated and we were able to
do some modifications to our processing
to bring down the or to to further
reduce the amount of variability from
point to point
and this just shows us a plot of the
Delta Delta CT comparison between the
the predecessor script and the express
96 it's hard to tell but they're
basically overlapping each other so they
they are basically the same you get the
same correlation slope and intercept
when you compare the plots of the two
against each other
and then in terms of being able to
increase your lab capacity I mean what
this the Express Scripts which are
available Beyond just PGX we didn't
develop them just for PGX they apply to
any application that can be run on our
gene expression or genotyping ifcs but
these offer
um the labs who may have a higher
throughput need to do more runs per day
without investing more resources and
Capital Equipment space in the lab also
even if you're not getting more capacity
in the lab you get your results faster
so certainly any everybody likes to get
the results as quickly as possible so
this is those two of the other two of
the key benefits of these Express
Scripts
and I'll skip past the summary just in
the interest of time so we have some
time at the end for Q a
so this gets into a performance a few
sections on performance I thought I've
been asked a few times in interactions
in the field how the extraction versus
extraction free Compares so this is
intended it provides an overview of how
what we've observed with our own
performance testing so the first study
was to look at extracted versus
extraction free the objective was to
measure concordance between the two from
Buckle swab samples that were paired as
part of the study design we looked at or
we collected two buckle swabs from eight
individuals we processed them in
parallel using a prescribed protocol and
tested four replicates per donor with
each prep method on the same IFC so
we're trying to reduce the number of
variables as as best we could so that
the focus really was on the methodology
itself for processing and our success
criteria going into this was that
greater than 95 concordance was required
between the two methods
and so if you kind of just follow the
schematic here that you've got your
collection on your far left they were
split um to based on the methodology the
bottom shows the extraction free
workflow which takes about 45 minutes on
top you've got the extraction method in
this case we use the Beckman culture
system uh not the mag Max that I
mentioned earlier
um and you can see it's a longer process
and it also involves use of another kit
so extraction kits especially over covid
were hard to come by in some cases so
one of the things we've tried to do is
minimize the amount of extra external
materials needed to use our app to
perform our applications so here we've
got the two compared and it shows you
just the general workflow
and if you look at the results the
focusing kind of on the the far right
right of the screen it shows you the the
the metrics that we measured so for the
snip assays and the CMD assays we were
getting about 100 and 97 respectively
and the first RL calls we were close to
100 all of which was above our our
preset metric of being needing to be
above 95 so that's why they're green in
all cases the results we observed past
the preset criteria
we then looked at genomic DNA sample
performance versus known ground truth or
known or what we also referred in-house
as ground truth so the objective in this
study was to measure the concordance
between known truth samples that were
well characterized versus what we were
observing with uh our assay using corial
genomic DNA so in this case we were
using 173 corial samples with
established genotype and CMV results
which we defined as ground truth and
then these were run using our assay and
again our acceptance criteria success
criteria was greater than 95 concordance
between extraction free and extracted
samples
if you look at the performance again
very solid performance that we were
observing upwards of 99 98 99 uh
concordance between Snips and cmvs which
was well above our requirement of
greater than 95 so again this past our
our prescribed requirements for the
application
and then finally we looked at the
extracted genomic DNA concentration
distribution so if you go the extracted
route what could you expect to see in
terms of the distribution of genomic
concentration based on the buccal swap
process we were using and so we were
using the Beckman Holter DNA Advanced
kit for processing the buccal swabs and
in the results you can see in the figure
on the slide the distribution of genomic
DNA was between seven or like
approximately eight or seven and
eighteen uh nanograms
um and that was just to understand what
the expected range we should uh we
should what we would likely see for a
customer who's trying to emulate and use
this particular application
so conclusions we had high concordance
across the board for copy number
detection star allele calls genotyping
calls and then the the range I mentioned
for concentration with the Beckman based
extraction method
moving into our Early Access program
here I'm going to go through the results
from three sites that are focusing on
the first site because it was it was
representative of all the sites in all
cases these sites had prior experience
with genotyping or I'm sorry with
pharmacogenomics testing so they came
into this with uh with uh subject matter
expertise in this area
um this just kind of shows you some of
the feedback we received the first site
indicated that they they really liked
the biomark X which is now the X9 system
they felt it was very flexible based on
what it could do they liked the
portability and size and thought that
the the looks of the instrument were
super good according to
um the quote we received from them they
also like that the workflow was very
simple to integrate in the lab because
it was nearly identical to something
they'd been doing already
the second site was very happy with the
workflow they liked the performance on
their especially when they used some of
their 10 year old DNA samples that they
had banked and wanted to try and they
wanted to run the whole panel as soon as
possible so the way we approach the
Early Access program it was early enough
in the development that we didn't have
the entire panel completed we had a good
portion of it completed that's what they
evaluated and then once the panel was
completed we allowed them to go back and
test the entire panel
and then the third site they like the
data quality they've used a droplet
digital PCR before for Snips and they
felt that our assay was easier to
operate they were pleased with the
results that they observed and the
overall Early Access process was
seamless with no hassles and they
considered the IFC loading as easy
ifcs are a novel device they are unique
to standard biotools and so it can be a
little bit of a learning curve for new
operators but in this case they adopted
it quite readily it seemed like it was
pretty easy for them to do
so I'll Focus the rest of this section
on just the results of the first EAP
site because it was representative of
what all the others observed so you can
see here as a summary
um what they tested they tested 85
control samples using the subset of our
design as I mentioned it was an early
predicate or early precursor of the
final design they ran two ifcs with the
control samples and a third IFC with
their samples and what they observed was
100 reproducibility between the two runs
that were using controls and they found
nine they got 99.98 call rate and 99.9
concordance for snip genotyping between
the runs and 100 call rate in
concordance for cmvs as well so very
strong performance for both cnbs and
snips
this particular site was it had been
using the Illumina beat array and they
indicated they felt that it was too much
it generated too much data such that the
users were not able to easily extract
actionable information and they did
report some issues with data quality and
reproducibility that they didn't get
into too much detail they just gave us
an overall indication that they had some
issues
um and they felt that our panel was
right-sized to allow for easy extraction
of actionable information and it
provided a high level of reproducibility
CMB concordance and snip call rate
and when they used it in their lab
this just goes into some of the
performance similar data that was
generated through our R D team when they
were looking at the tacman probe-based
chemistry here's an example of what we
saw for single nucleotide polymorphisms
again really good separation of the
Clusters between our homozygous and
heterozygous segments
and then for the tacman-based chemistry
for copy numbers here we're just looking
at the assays designed to measure 0 1 2
and 3 or more copies for three regions
of the sip2d gene that's the five Prime
utr intron 6 and X9 Exon 9 which are
commonly used for zip2d6 analysis
and rnasp is used as an assay control
what we determine copy number through
real-time PCR we use four chambers or
four Inlet four replicants per assay to
get statistical power and then the
formula for determining Delta Delta CT
is shown on the bottom of the slide
and here you've got some data just
showing as kind of distill this down as
you have you go from one copy to two
copies to three copies you can see that
blue curve which represents the five
Prime utr the the the the the signal
comes in earlier that the CT values rise
earlier in the cycling process which is
expected as you would expect more copies
to generate a stronger signal earlier
and then we'll close out today with the
analysis software we do provide a
package that's designed to support the
assay as well as the instrumentation
that's used with it these are all
available for download from our website
if you go to uh the link shown at the
bottom of the screen all of these
applications are readily available for
download
and it includes a preset file which is
something new that we've developed to
streamline the application the user
experience when running this application
and the preset file which is specific to
PGX it contains all the default analysis
settings designed and optimized for our
assay and you can consult with our
Representatives if you're at least early
on for labs that are planning to
customize further we would like to work
with you to make sure that the
customization of the preset is also
going smoothly
so breaking this out into workflow the
the top part of the slide shows the
various interactions that the user
performs whereas the bottom focuses on
automated activities performed by the
system so focusing first on the user
they would load the IFC into the
instrument and select the PGX assay
button or the preset from the instrument
screen to start the run and apply the
preset parameters
they would then export the data to a USB
or a network drive for analysis once the
run is completed
um they would then take the um the
generic sample and acid annotations on
the on the file and up to update them
accordingly to be
um run specific so you'd have your
specific samples that you want to run in
any customization that you've done to
the on the assay side would be annotated
by the user and then they open the files
and the analysis software
and then from there these the system
takes over so we'll then take the the
system creates two chip run files from
the exported data one is for the Snips
and one is for the cmds and these are
then combined with the annotations and
the assay names
um that are in the files provided by the
user
and then they would apply the system the
system then it applies the preset
parameters for analysis and Reporting
and then determines all the snip CMV and
star allele calls and then it finally
issues the report with all this
information for review by the by the um
the lab personnel
this just shows you an example of this
snip assay setup file that we provide it
comes as a preset and then if somebody's
trying to customize the assay they could
they can make modifications as needed
and that's where we would want to work
with you to make sure that it's being
done smoothly and understand and
appreciate what experience you're having
trying to implement this as it's been
designed that way if there's needs to
make refinements later we can look into
doing so
we use a a truth table for our star
allele calls so we take the snip output
data from the system and compare it to a
preset truth table and here's an example
just showing the table on the lower
right it shows you examples of star
alleles for the different um for sip2d6
as an example and if you're trying in
this case to look look at is it star 10
star 10 you would need to have a
specific pattern of snips to make that
call so that's how we're doing this it's
all pattern based recognition
there's also on the CMV side rug plots
that show you the distribution of
samples based on the number of copies so
you can see in the figure on the left
I'm sorry I figure on the right you've
got the Four Peaks that represents zero
copies one copy two copies and three
plus copies and samples are are
distributed based on the profile of the
sample set that was used in this
particular example
but these reports we we provide all the
raw data for the cmvs not just a final
call that way if you want to make an
assessment whether perhaps a hybrid
allele is present you're able to look at
the pattern of the different assays to
use for copy number variation to say
perhaps the five prime utr number is
different than the X on the other two
Targets and you would make you could
make your call accordingly
and then you get your final report
output and this is a in the form of an
Excel table
um users can generate the report after
the after the annotations are completed
and user has the opt the option to
import customize sample and access
affiliate files as I mentioned earlier
if you're using a custom design
[Music]
then the final part of this section
before we go into q a is just to give
you a sense of what's provided in the
product it comes as a kit part number is
102-2242 and it includes all the sub
components shown on the slide basically
everything you need to perform the
application it one kit does support 480
samples or five independent runs of up
to 96 samples per run
history shows you a little bit more
about what's included in the kit all the
buffers sample prep all the way through
the assays the integrated fluidic
circuits and other reagents needed to
perform the application the Buckle swabs
and other lab consumables are not
included but those are available from
various lab suppliers and for the Buckle
swabs I did mention what um which ones
we've tried in our own lab
which all worked well
so closing out on the recap of the user
benefits and the key features the first
three on this slide show you the use of
extraction free Buckle swabs single
workflow for Snips and cmvs and the
Express Script those together produce a
simpler and shorter workflow and reduce
the amount of Hands-On time for the
operator
you look at the panel of fixed content
of 74 targets along with the option to
add nine custom Targets this gives you
an actionable panel based on guidelines
but also provides the flexibility and
opportunity to differentiate based on
what your lab needs are in terms of the
indications for testing for
pharmacogenomics
and then finally the ability to add
remove change assays provides a level of
adaptability that's not found in many
other applications and then the analysis
software does facilitate reporting
capabilities and is is compatible with
Downstream applications that can that
can be used for further interpretation
for for more information there's a I've
provided a few links to our website if
you go to the the standard biotools
website we've got a product page now for
pharmacogenomics there's a separate set
of pages for microfluidics in general if
you want to learn more about
microfluidics as well as information
about our X9 system and hopefully you've
had uh that you've enjoyed today's
presentation and we'll open it up for
some questions